PROFESSOR: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video I want us to
look at the following problem.
We're going to let f
of x equal 1 over x.
And I want to consider
the solid generated
by rotating f of x about
the x-axis between x
equal 1 and x equal infinity.
I want you to find the area
of a cross-sectional slice,
and then I want you to find
the volume of the solid.
In the cross-sectional slice,
the one I'm interested in
is the one that you
see in the xy-plane.
So my suggestion to you is
that right away draw yourself
a picture, just at least a
rough sketch of the curve y
equals f of x, and then what
that cross-sectional slice
will look like and
start off from there.
And take a while to work
on that and then I'll
be back and show you what I did.
OK welcome back.
Well, hopefully you were
able to make some headway
on this problem, and maybe you
found some interesting things.
Hopefully you did.
And we will see what I find
and if they are interesting,
which I think they are.
So let's start off.
I told you the first
thing you should do
is get a rough picture.
So I'm going to
draw a rough picture
and make sure that
those match up well,
that my picture
matches up with yours.
So let me give you the xy-plane.
And then y equals 1 over x is
a curve that at x equal 1--
I'm going to make
y equal 1 up here.
y equal 1 up there. x equal 1.
So when x is 1, y is 1.
And then it's going
to decay down.
As x goes to infinity it decays
So it looks something like that.
And then I actually
should have moved this 1
because I'm going to
need that side to get
my cross-sectional slice.
So my cross sectional
slice is going
to come down here and
look something like this.
Oops, that's supposed
to be symmetric.
That's still supposed to
be something like this.
It's supposed to be
symmetric about the x-axis.
And the cross-sectional
slice is the area of that.
Now, if you remember
what you saw in lecture.
You saw, I believe,
that the integral from 1
to infinity of 1
over x dx diverges,
because you end up with
log evaluated at infinity
and that is infinite and
so you wind up with this.
This actually diverges.
That was the area of the
top part from 0 to f of x.
So of course if I
double that, I'm still
going to get that it diverges.
So in fact the cross sectional
slice area, CSS area,
is infinite.
OK, so that's one part.
The other part is
to find the volume
of the solid of revolution.
So the second part was take
this piece from 0 up to f of x,
rotate it around the x-axis
and compute the volume.
Now we know how to
compute the volume.
This is the disc method
that I'm going to use here.
And I will write out
what we need to do
and then we'll look at
what the integral gives us.
So for the disc method, so let's
say this is the volume part.
So the volume, it's going
to be the disc method.
So I need to do pi r squared.
And in this case I'm
integrating from 1 to infinity,
so I need pi r squared dx.
I'm going to be
integrating something
that's pi r squared dx.
And I know the bounds
are 1 to infinity,
and so I need r in terms
of, as a function of x.
That's fairly easy. r is
just the measure from 0 up
to f of x.
So that's just 1 over x.
So this is actually
the integral--
I'm going to pull
the pi out-- of 1
over x squared from
1 to infinity dx.
OK so how do I do this integral?
Well you were shown in
class that in actuality this
is the limit, as some value
up here goes to infinity,
of this integral,
but we're just going
to do it the shorthand way
that he also mentioned in class
and keep the infinity around.
So we can keep
that as our bounds,
knowing we're taking limits as
this thing goes to infinity.
So the integral of 1 over x
squared is negative 1 over x.
So I get minus pi times 1 over
x, evaluated at 1 in infinity.
I can just check
that if I need to,
but this is x to the minus
1 and its derivative is
negative x to the minus 2.
So I needed that negative there.
And then I evaluate this.
Well at infinity, 1 over
x-- as x goes to infinity,
this first part goes to 0.
So this is 0 minus
negative pi times 1 over 1.
So negative pi times 1.
So this is just pi.
OK, so hopefully that kind of
blows your mind a little bit,
that you could have
something where
this cross-sectional slice
is infinite, but in fact
if you look at it the way
we computed the volume,
we have in fact a finite volume.
So I don't know
what else I'm going
to say about that except
I think it's really cool.
And you can think
about why that is.
And in fact you
might want to notice
that we had to--
we computed things
in terms of
cross-sectional slices
coming from the other direction.
So we looked at these
cross-sectional slices
and we got our-- we showed
our volume was finite there.
So we had a sum of a
bunch of finite things
and so it made sense that
you were going to get--
and the finite things were
getting small fast enough.
That's the point.
That when you add up
these finite things that
are getting small fast
enough, you can still
end up with a finite number.
But I guess, yeah,
that's where I'll stop.
So just to say that we were
looking at this sort of solid
of revolution
problem again, but we
were dealing with
improper integrals,
and we were showing how you
can do these kinds of problems
with improper integrals.
So now I really will stop there.